[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
19 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty happy that
finally GCP Next is over.
That was pretty epic.
MARK MANDEL: That was--
I think epic is actually
the right word for it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It was awesome,
in the true sense of the word.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There was lots of, lots
of, lots of interviews.
But yeah.
Actually, what was
your favorite part?
MARK MANDEL: Man.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So many things.
MARK MANDEL: I think for
me, it may probably biased,
because we were sitting right
in the middle of the playground.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We were.
MARK MANDEL: But the playground.
I love the playground.
I was so happy to see so many
cool, interactive things,
that people could like look
at from the data center 360,
to the Emotobooth
where they could
sort of interact with the
Vision API, the vision bots.
Like just being able
to see people get hands
on with the stuff we run
a Google Cloud Platform.
And like, interact with
it a really fun way.
I think that was
really rewarding.
I really enjoyed that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That was actually lots of fun.
We interviewed a bunch of
people from Instrument,
the company that helped
us build those demos.
And it was really amazing.
To the point that if you
go to our Twitter page,
Twitter.com/gcppodcast
you'll see that we changed
our picture.
And now we actually
have her picture
taken with the Emotobooth.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think you might see that
picture show up in a few places
once I integrate it with a
few more of our services.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was an awesome picture.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
No, that was great.
They asked us to show surprise,
and I think we showed surprise.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We're very, very good
at being surprised.
MARK MANDEL: Very much so.
Very much so.
But I know the keynotes
were pretty amazing.
They were all
really, really great.
So we've got, for
our listeners today,
I think, a bunch of
interviews that we
did with speakers at the event.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Should
we share the number
of interviews we made in
a day, in only two days?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So if you weren't
at the event, we--
How many interviews did we do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was 43 interviews,
something like that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so we
interviewed a whole bunch
of people, 3-minute,
5-minute, 10-minute interviews
at GCP Next.
We had all our gear there.
And it was just nonstop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was pretty crazy.
It was a very noisy
environment, so I
wanted to thank
again Brian Dorsey
for the amazing equipment
that allowed us to record
all the things we recorded.
And they actually sound great.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
They sound great.
And thanks so much to everyone
who came by at the table,
sat down with us,
had a chat, told us
about their experiences,
what they were building,
how they felt about the event.
We're definitely, I think, going
to feed in a bunch of content
into episodes past this one--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For
the next years or so.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, probably
until the next GCP Next.
We're just going
to roll it through.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty happy
with how all that turned out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
actualy, the cool thing
of the week for this week is
going to be related to that.
And the main content of the week
is going to be related to that.
And then the
question of the week
is going to be related to that.
Today it's a GCP Next episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's totally a GSP Next episode.
So yeah, main content, we're
going to be doing interviews
with speakers.
We've got five speakers.
Actually more than that,
because we have some people--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we have five interviews
with a bunch of speakers.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
So we talked with them.
And then we also have a question
of the week from someone
who came by and talked to
us at the event, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So what is the cool
thing of the week, then?
MARK MANDEL: So the cool thing
of the week is, funnily enough,
GCP related, is we've
released all the YouTube
videos for GCP Next.
So if you're interested
in the keynotes,
if you're interested
in any presentations,
I might be in one of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I actually watched three
of the talks already.
One was yours.
Where you talk about
dragons on the cloud,
which is pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then, Justin
Beckwith PM Google Cloud
Platform that he does
a lot of Node.js,
talking about how to make his
noogler hat spin through bits,
like little bits.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was a very--
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was
a very interesting talk.
And yeah.
And then I actually
like-- I'm waiting
to watch Julia
Ferraioli's talk on how
to train neural networks to
know if something is huggable
or not.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds really cool.
And we will be talking to
Julia in a little bit, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we'll be
talking to Julia in a minute.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So if people listen to the
speaker interviews that
are about to come up and they
want to see the presentations,
they should be online.
And all the other stuff to
keep notes from Sundar Pichai,
from everyone else.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Eric Schmidt.
That was an great talk.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, it was.
They're all online.
So you can definitely
check that out.
Excellent.
So shall we get started with the
interviews from our speakers?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds
like a good idea.
Let's go for that.
So we're here with Mike Kavis.
Hi, Mike.
How are you doing?
MIKE KAVIS: Very good.
It's been a great show so far.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
And you work for Cloud
technology partners?
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah,
we're a Boston based
firm that helps companies
get to the cloud,
whether they're migrating
apps, or building net new.
And we do a lot of work
on the Google Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about what kind of
products you use with them?
And what is your
favorite product,
or the favorite product for
your customers, actually?
MIKE KAVIS: Well,
my personal favorite
is the whole big
data suite of things,
you know, Dataflow,
Pub/Sub, BigQuery.
I mean, most-- You
know, I've been
working in data
warehousing my whole life.
And the hardest part is
always getting the data in.
And at Google, it's just
a couple APIs and a couple
configurations, and
the hard part's done.
And then you actually focus
on getting the results out
of the data.
That's a game
changer in my eyes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So I assuming, you also work
with Bigtable a little bit.
What do you think
about Bigtable?
It's quite a new product.
Have you used it?
MIKE KAVIS: Well, I mean,
again, my background
is data warehousing.
I remember buying
appliances like Netezza
that costs zillions of dollars.
And you go dark for a
year, just setting up
the infrastructure and stuff.
And now you get tools
like BigQuery, Bigtable,
and you're just up and running.
And getting results that
are 10 times faster than you
can get any place else.
It's just-- It's just
kind of amazing, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, wonderful.
And so I believe you're
here at GCP Next.
You presented?
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah, I
was on a panel talking
about cloud migrations,
which is kind
of a new chapter
for Google, right?
I mean, originally it
was all about the future
of development, with all
these high level services.
But I think the
realization comes
is you've got to get
people on a platform first.
So now there's a big
focus on cloud migration.
We do a lot of
work in that space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
MARK MANDEL: When you
say cloud migration,
is that specifically like
moving from one cloud
provider to another?
What does that really mean?
MIKE KAVIS: It could
be, but normally it's
moving from on-prem
to the cloud.
And the biggest use case is
always we have 20 data centers.
We've got to get to
3 by x date, which
is usually very aggressive.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MIKE KAVIS: So
the good is people
are moving fast to the cloud.
The bad is they're
lifting and shifting,
so they're not getting
advantage of the cloud.
But that's the next wave.
Once you get them
there, then you
start helping them
re-architect or build net New.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
So for people that are doing
that shifting and lifting,
I'm assuming that most of them
did just move to Google Compute
Engine.
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah.
So in a lot of cases again,
they're time crunched.
So it's get what I
have in the cloud.
So they're treating Google more
like a virtual data center.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I see.
MIKE KAVIS: And they don't have
the time yet, to take advantage
of those higher level services.
That's-- Once you
get them there,
then you move them up the stack.
MARK MANDEL: It's a foot
in the door type situation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: When you
say move them up the stack,
could you tell everybody
more about that?
Is it like a container
engine, or do you
move them to App Engine?
How does that work?
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah,
that's a loaded term.
And it means so many
things to so many people.
What I really mean is getting
them to use the more high value
API, so getting them
to use Kubernetes,
getting them to use
BigQuery, Dataflow,
and all those services
where you no longer have
to focus on the infrastructure
and the plumbing.
It kind of does it for you.
And then you can focus on
building apps and doing
the machine
learning, and getting
insights, and stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is actually a little bit
of what Urs was mentioning there
in the keynote, about the
serverless architecture.
Not because there's no service,
but because you don't really
care about them anymore.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was very interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Really moving up
to another level of abstraction.
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah,
and the challenge is,
most of these enterprises
are just figuring out
what cloud is, so
you start talking
about serverless stuff, their
eyes just kind of glaze over.
And sometimes it takes
them stumbling and fumbling
on the cloud for a couple years
till they get it and start
moving up the value chain
and taking those high level
services.
The companies that have been
in the cloud for a while,
they get it.
And they're salivating
over new stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: So
speaking of the keynote,
did you have a particular
launch or product or demo?
What was your favorite part?
MIKE KAVIS: I liked a lot
of the machine learning
prediction stuff.
I liked that a lot.
We're getting a lot of projects.
You know, sometimes
you're labeled IoT.
Sometimes you're
labeled big data.
But there's a lot
of companies who are
harvesting sensor information.
And their first step is just
to get it all in one place.
But their ultimate goal is, what
can we learn from this data?
And how can we
offer new services?
How can we change an industry?
Or how can we change
pricing models?
So a lot of companies are
early in that journey.
And you know, we're helping
them get the data in one place.
Because right now,
machine learning
is an art and a science.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MIKE KAVIS: And you're trying to
make that so any developer can
kind of tap into that.
MARK MANDEL: Sort
of a commodity.
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah.
And I'm looking forward to that.
I know there's a lot
of work yet to do.
But that's a good
direction to be going.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
Did you get the
chance to play earlier
a bit with the playground
activities, our Query It
and the photo booth and so on?
MIKE KAVIS: No, I actually have
been running between sessions.
And we have a booth
here, so I've been--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK.
MIKE KAVIS: --kind of going
back and forth between that.
But I see a Tetris
machine over there.
I might have to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very cool.
Well thank you so much
for being with us today.
And see you later.
MIKE KAVIS: All
right, appreciate it.
Thanks, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: We are joined
here by Niels Provos, who
is hot off the stage from
the keynote this morning.
How are you doing today, Niel?
NIELS PROVOS: I'm
doing just fine.
Glad that I'm done with my
obligations for the day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is good.
NIELS PROVOS: It took
a while to prepare.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, I bet it did.
Do you want to give us a
really quick 30-second synopsis
of what you just
presented on stage?
NIELS PROVOS: Sure.
So in Google, I'm responsible
for security and privacy
engineering.
Google has spent many,
many years creating
a very, very secure platform.
And so for GCP customers
who are wondering,
what does that mean for us?
So during that talk I
essentially said trust
and transparency is
very important to us.
Let me explain to
you how we have
built Google's infrastructure
to be secure, and then relay
to you what that means
as a customer for running
on top of GCP.
And so I essentially started
from the bottom-- trusted
hardware, trusted boot,
cryptographic identities
for our jobs, DDoS protection,
unfishible user identities
with [INAUDIBLE] second
factor, and then gave
some examples of how
customers can leverage that
on top of GCP.
For example, storage
encryption happens
by default. For
Google App Engine,
we give you our Cloud
Security Scanner,
to find vulnerabilities such as
Access S or mixed content, mix
pinning.
I talked a little
bit about our efforts
to secure the TLS
certificate infrastructure,
with certificate
transparency, where
we have worked for years to
create a model where all issued
certificates can be verified
in a publicly available lock.
And sort of just ran people
through the security stamps
they get for running on
GCP, and some of the things
that we are thinking of
giving them in the future.
So for example, we are working
on a key management system
and those kind of things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
That sounds like a
lot of information.
So if anyone is more interested,
the keynote was recorded.
And you should definitely
check the video out.
I was actually checking
it out while we were here.
It was a very good presentation.
Congratulations on that.
There's a specific topic that
we get a question quite often,
which is DDoS.
NIELS PROVOS: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Can
you tell me a bit more?
Where is that DDoS
protection coming and taking
place for Google Cloud Platform?
NIELS PROVOS: So when
you run on our platform,
you essentially benefit from
our serving infrastructure
as a network.
If you let's say enable HTTPS
load balancing that gets
served via an
infrastructure that
has DDoS protection built in.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
NIELS PROVOS: Actually,
during the talk,
I got to share a little
bit that we have extended
that protection, also the news
and human rights organization,
election monitoring sites,
which seems like a timely topic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was very cool.
And I heard the audience
clapping to that.
NIELS PROVOS: They did.
I had not expected
that, to be honest.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
MARK MANDEL: No,
that's very cool.
And just so we're
clear, because this
is something I'm interested
in, is it specifically HTTPS?
Or do you have the
same protection
on like HTTP and network?
NIELS PROVOS: With the lower
balancer, does HTTP and HTTPS.
But to be perfectly
honest, look,
if you're running on
the internet these days,
you'd better protect
yourself with TLS, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
NIELS PROVOS: Google
has been pushing
to encrypt all of our traffic.
We have just made the
Transparency Report
available last week that
sort of tracks our progress.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
NIELS PROVOS: And
there's no excuse
for anybody putting a
website on the internet
not to use encryption.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Coming from
a responsible for the security
for Google Cloud Platform,
sounds pretty normal.
MARK MANDEL: Very good.
Thank you so much for
coming and talking to us.
NIELS PROVOS: Yeah, my pleasure.
Looking forward to it, bye.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: We've been
joined by two speakers
here at our table, James
Malone and Frances Perry.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
FRANCES PERRY: Thank you.
JAMES MALONE: It's
nice to be here.
MARK MANDEL: How are
you both doing today?
JAMES MALONE: Awesome.
FRANCES PERRY: Doing well.
Enjoying meeting people.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So I know you were speaking
about some interesting stuff
here at GCP Next.
Do you want to give us a
little brief overview of what
it is you were talking about?
JAMES MALONE: Absolutely.
So we gave a talk
yesterday that was
focused on creating what
we call next generation
data processing, where
people don't have
to fight with infrastructure.
They don't have to
worry about using
the multiple tools to try and
do batch and stream processing.
And they can trust that
their data pipelines are
going to be portable both on GCP
or between clouds or on cloud
and on-premise.
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah.
We started with a little
history of MapReduce,
and how that new programming
paradigm really changed the way
that we at data processing.
And we talk about how that
diverges a little bit.
So inside Google, after that
MapReduce paper was published,
we continued innovating.
We had a lot of new
ideas that we kept doing.
But it was this really
homogeneous environment, right?
Within Google, we just
have a few file formats,
a few languages.
And some very
standardized tooling.
So we really went
deep on the right way
to do data processing.
But we were able to go
very deep because we
were very homogeneous.
Whereas externally,
the ecosystem
looked very different.
They took the MapReduce paper,
implemented it in Hadoop,
and then this whole
ecosystem flourished
with all these diverse ideas.
And now we've got
basically two products
in GCP that build
on that legacy.
JAMES MALONE: Google
Cloud Dataproc,
which is a managed Spark
and Hadoop offering.
FRANCES PERRY: And then
Google Cloud Dataflow,
which is our basically
next generation way
for writing programs.
It's really going to
combine batch and streaming
into one API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
I got to say that
Google Cloud Dataflow is
one of my favorite products,
to the point that--
FRANCES PERRY: Mine too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
will write Java for it.
I never write Java.
And so far, the only
language that is supported
is Java, so I actually write--
FRANCES PERRY: Ah, ah.
You need to read your
blogs, my friend.
Yesterday we announced Python
alpha support for batch.
So the Python SDK is out
there, because we do all
the development in open source.
So it's out there on GitHub.
And now we have an alpha
program for service support
to run it on Cloud Dataflow
on the fully managed service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know
a lot of people that
will be very happy about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
You're only one of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
will be one of them.
I prefer Python.
It's still not Go, but it's
better than Java for me.
That is awesome.
FRANCES PERRY: What we're
really excited about.
When we donated the data flow
model in these first two SDKs
that we developed to the
Apache Software Foundation
as this new incubating
project Apache Beam,
the real goal behind that is
to put the framework out there,
the programming model, and
then the documentation that
will allow other developers
who like other languages-- Go
or Scholar or
Ruby-- basically let
people add to this community
and add new languages and also
new runners.
If you've got a different
distributed processing
back end that
you're a fan of, you
can run Beam pipelines on
that, add that capability
into the system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
MARK MANDEL: So
you're able to sort
of leverage that wider
community to help
build upon that platform.
FRANCES PERRY: Right.
MARK MANDEL: Exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Can we know a little bit
more about the other side
of the big data?
Not only Cloud
Dataflow, but data--
MARK MANDEL: Cloud Dataproc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I was
going to say Dataproc, yeah.
I always mix Dataproc and
Datalabs for some reason.
Dataproc.
FRANCES PERRY: Data everything.
JAMES MALONE: Why would
you mix product names that
have data all in them?
That's just crazy.
You're obviously not
reading your Google supply
of flash cards.
So yeah, Cloud Dataproc, it's
built around a different set
of open source tools.
So in our talk
yesterday-- and Frances
just mentioned this--
the MapReduce paper kind
of set off two parallel streams.
And one Google ultimately
led to Cloud Data
And another was the
open source community
took the MapReduce paper and
created just a whole ecosystem
around it.
So they created Apache Hadoop,
Apache Spark, [INAUDIBLE],
Hive.
There's probably 30
or 40 different logos.
And Cloud Dataproc
is designed to allow
people to take advantage of
that open source ecosystem.
But it combines that
open source ecosystem
with Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm looking at mixer, and
there's like only a few knobs
on that.
An open source product usually
has a couple hundred knobs
a piece.
And Cloud Dataproc is
designed to help people
take advantage of that stuff
without having to be an expert
and buy a ton of
books and know exactly
which memory settings to
do, and all that fun stuff.
MARK MANDEL: So I can pretty
much go to it and be like, OK,
it's going to give me some
best practices and some boxes
to explain what
certain things are.
And then I can be
like, boop, boop, boop,
and then there we go.
JAMES MALONE: Yeah.
So you can go and create a--
FRANCES PERRY: It
makes that noise, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
boop, boop, boop.
JAMES MALONE: Yeah.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
You can go and create a
cluster of, like, 100 computers
all tied together and do
some awesomely parallel data
processing on them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us today.
JAMES MALONE: Yeah.
FRANCES PERRY: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you later.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
JAMES MALONE: Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: Coming
right off the stage
we have Julia Ferraioli
joining us here at the table.
Julia how you doing today?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: I'm well.
How are you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very well.
Francesc how are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm great.
I'm actually very happy
that Julia is here,
because since we're
here on the floor,
we're not watching the talks.
And everyone that I heard
that went to your talk
was very excited about it,
and they said it was amazing.
Tell us a little bit about it.
What did you talk about?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Well, so,
yesterday at the keynote,
Jeff Dean announced one
of our new platforms,
which is our machine learning
platform, Cloud Machine
Learning.
And so, my session dove into
a little bit of the details
surrounding what
machine learning can do,
what kind of problems it can
solve, and how does it do that.
MARK MANDEL: So I believe
one of the problems you're
looking at solving was
something to do with hugs.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Well, you know,
sometimes I like a sanity check
here and there, telling me if
I should actually hug something
or not.
Speaking, I'm somebody
who accidentally
hugged a cactus once.
So I'm intimately familiar with
things that you shouldn't hug.
So what we were
really trying to do
is do an image
classification problem.
Now, the Vision API, which
is a part of Google's machine
learning platform, does
things like identify
what is in an image.
But what it can't do is tell
you if you should hug it.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Naturally.
MARK MANDEL: Naturally.
And that's a common
problem I have as well.
I understand completely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Huggability
is a very important feature.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right.
So what we did was,
I actually sent out
a survey to my team
asking them to tell me
what are examples of things
that they would or wouldn't hug.
I got some really
interesting answers back.
So I went out and I
found example images
of each of those things.
I took about 160
images of things
that people said
that they would hug,
and 160 that they
wouldn't hug, and used
those to train a classifier
that we can use on any image
to give us some information
about whether or not it's
a good idea to hug that object.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm curious.
What results did you get at
the end of it that were either
more interesting or
surprising that you may not
have been expecting?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Well, OK,
so I trained the classifier
over things like puppies,
kittens, you know,
the usual suspects, clouds,
dandelions, and pillows.
So these were things that
people said that they would hug.
And it was really
important to get
things that were
organic and inorganic,
right, so that you
get a nice spectrum.
In the not hug category, we
got things like shark's teeth,
broken glass, puffer
fish, stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Makes sense.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
So I did two tests.
I uploaded a picture of an
octopus from an aquarium.
Now my classifier said,
no, don't hug that, maybe.
Somebody said, E-- too
many hugs, as an error.
I didn't actually get that,
but amounts to the same thing.
But when I uploaded a
picture of an octopus
that somebody had crocheted,
so like a stuffed animal
octopus, that got a really
nice score saying, yeah,
you should hug that.
And I just thought that was
absolutely fascinating, right?
Because it's taking,
at a high level,
the same subject but with
a different implementation.
And it's able to differentiate
between those two.
I thought that was amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So neural network, modeling
the huggability of stuff.
That is amazing.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: I don't believe
it's been done before, I think.
This might be new.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
pretty sure it is.
I never heard about
someone who was like, yeah,
how huggable are things?
That's amazing.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's very cool.
So yes we announced
a lot of things
about machine
learning yesterday,
but what was your
favorite announcement,
other than machine
learning, of course?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Oh, my
favorite announcement.
Well, you know, since I
started working on cloud,
I've always been
enamored with BigQuery.
The first time I heard the
architecture described to me,
I was like, wow, this is, A,
completely unintuitive to me.
I would have never
thought of this.
So of course, I love it.
And B, it just
makes so much sense.
And it's something
that really takes
the power of what
we're doing at Google
and delivers it
to everybody else.
So they made some really
cool announcements
on price cuts in architecture
with how BigQuery actually
works yesterday.
And I'm not an expert,
so I can't diagram it out
for you in any way.
This is a podcast, so you
couldn't see it anyway.
But I think those might be
my other favorites of Next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, thank you so much,
Julia, for being here,
taking the time to
talk to us today.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And looking
forward towards that video.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Me too.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Bye.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
here with Neil Palmer and Todd
Ricker from FIS Global.
And they just came out of
giving an amazing talk.
So we wanted to
interview a little bit,
know a little bit
who you are first.
So why don't you go first, Neil?
NEIL PALMER: Sure.
FIS is the world's largest
financial services technology
firm.
We provide software
for everything
from online banking to ATMs
through to asset management
risk surveillance
for the big banks.
My world's a little
bit different.
We run an incubator
group where we
look at emerging technologies
and figure out what they're
going to mean for our business.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
[INAUDIBLE]
TODD RICKER: I work very
closely with Neil day to day.
And I'm a Java developer,
Scala developer on the side,
cloud computing, you name it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Can you tell us a little
bit how you use the cloud?
NEIL PALMER: So we were
just up there talking
about our bid for the
consolidated audit trail.
And this is the next generation
stock market reconstruction
system that the SEC is
looking to put together.
One of the issues
with the current stock
market and the
regulatory systems
is there's a lot of them.
It's very disparate.
It's kind of hard
for people to know
what happens when something
goes wrong in the stock market.
So this next system, the goal
is to be able to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
So you'd be able to actually
not only follow the market
but actually understand
what goes on?
NEIL PALMER: Yeah.
So there was what's called
the Flash Crash back in 2010,
where several trillion dollars
were wiped off the US markets.
MARK MANDEL: Nothing serious.
NEIL PALMER: Nothing serious.
And then it vanished and
then mysteriously reappeared,
which, you know, I
have trouble when
that's $20 out of my wallet, let
alone several trillion dollars.
And so there's still
arguments happening today,
six years later, about
what actually happened.
And it's not a good thing for
the well-ordered functioning
of our society.
MARK MANDEL: And are
you looking basically
to leverage the
power of the cloud
and certain aspects of,
maybe, compute, maybe
machine learning,
other things that you
can expand that sort of power
of computing [INAUDIBLE]?
NEIL PALMER: Right.
So we've been partnered
with Google from the get go.
So we're pretty much
using every piece of GCP.
We were just announcing the
results of our new load test.
We processed 25 billion fixed
messages in about 50 minutes
end to end.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
NEIL PALMER: We hit peak of
about, reads, 38 gigs a second,
writes, about 22 gigs
a second going through.
So it's pretty smokin'.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And I assume that's
what you were talking
about in your session today.
NEIL PALMER: That's right.
That's right.
And so really, it's
our prototype to say,
we can handle the level of
data you're talking about.
You're talking
about the entire US
market has to be analyzed in
four hours on a daily basis.
And so it's not insignificant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very cool.
So since we're here
at GCP Next, I'm
assuming you had a look
at all the announcements,
the keynotes.
What was your favorite part?
What is the announcement that
got you the most excited?
TODD RICKER: Well, I demoed
some visualization tools.
And I think there was one
they showed in the keynote.
I don't remember the name.
But it was a really
brilliant visualization tool
for BigQuery.
And I'll definitely
go check that out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
What about you, Neil?
NEIL PALMER: Some of the
security conversations
are very important to me.
And so some of the talks
from Niels Provos were great.
You know, I think
I'm looking forward
to not just sort of the ongoing
security conversation with GCP
but-- you know,
in an ideal world,
all I want for Christmas is
you guys to expose your tool
chain around releasing
applications in GCP.
That would be awesome.
It happens already
with App Engine.
But it'd be kind of cool
if some of that stuff
was available for wider use.
TODD RICKER: Yeah.
An Eric Schmidt's vision of
a future for app development
was interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, Eric Schmidt,
when he was talking about
Google 3 [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, that is very interesting.
TODD RICKER: Time will tell.
It will be fun to watch.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely
going to think there's
some good stuff on the horizon.
So it sounds like you use
a variety of platform tools
at the moment.
If you had to pick one
that was your favorite,
which one would you pick?
NEIL PALMER: Well, if
we don't say Bigtable,
Carter will kill us.
So we love Bigtable.
We love Dataflow.
We love Dataflow, because
we went from a year ago,
the initial prototype
used-- so the [INAUDIBLE],
native Hadoop distribution,
which was fine, was great.
But the Dataflow stuff just
makes life so much easier.
The auto scaling is a
thing of joy to behold.
And so we love that one.
TODD RICKER: No, I agree.
Dataflow all the way.
In this platform, that's
how we express ourselves.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Yeah, anyway, Bigtable
plus Dataflow-- yeah.
That's a good team.
NEIL PALMER: And we
built this stuff.
It's not like we've got a team
of thousands of developers
out there, right?
We built that in
essentially a month
with a team of about six people.
MARK MANDEL: That is amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to come here to talk to us.
NEIL PALMER: Any time.
Our pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: Appreciate it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, thanks again
to all of those speakers
that took the time
to go by the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast booth
at GCP Next.
That's a mouthful.
Thank you for taking the
time to go by, talk to us,
and tell us that a bit
about what they were talking
and what they thought
about the conference.
One of the people that came and
talked to us was not a speaker.
He was actually
asking a question.
And we decided that could be
a great question of the week.
So let's hear it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
here with Romin Irani.
And he actually came to
ask some Go questions.
And we decided that
maybe this could
be the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So hi, Romin.
ROMIN IRANI: Hi.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Go for it.
What is your question?
ROMIN IRANI: Yeah,
so my question
is about using Go on App Engine.
You know, in previous, I've
been using App Engine with Java
and other languages.
And there's always
been this restriction
that you can't use certain
libraries and App Engine
as a fixed programming model.
So when it comes to Go,
are there any restrictions
for Go on App Engine?
What would be certain scenarios
in which Go on App Engine
is probably preferred compared
to Go on maybe Compute
Engine directly?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, that
is a very good question.
So to answer the first
part of the question, which
is, what restrictions do we
have on Go for App Engine,
they're pretty much
the same restrictions
that you can find for
Java on App Engine.
Meaning that every
request has to be answered
in less than 60 seconds.
You cannot write to the
file system directly.
And you cannot have
binary libraries.
Basically, you can only run Go.
And actually on top of that, you
cannot use the unsafe package,
because the unsafe package
is not really safe,
hence the name.
MARK MANDEL: There is
also some limitations,
which is pretty similar,
again, in terms of if you
want to make HTTP requests.
You have to use the
URL Fetch library.
And there's some
other stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But the
URL library, actually,
the URL Fetch library
also provides HTTP client
if you need to.
So it integrates quite well
with existing libraries
if you need to.
So for the second part
of the question, which
is, when could I
use Go on App Engine
or on Compute Engine,
what I could say
is if you're doing
web server stuff,
I could always go
with App Engine.
And that's mainly because
you're getting all the scaling
and zero management for free.
You're getting
that automatically,
which is really cool.
And if you have something which
is really similar to web server
but you need something specific
that is a limit-- for instance,
you need to use, I don't
know, regular expressions,
and regular expressions, you
want specific version written
in C, which is something
that we have, then
you will need to move to
Managed VMs, for instance.
So you still have that
scalability and the close
to zero management.
But you're now using
C or the file system
or whatever you need.
And otherwise--
yeah, Compute Engine,
I could do it when it's
not really a web server.
Like, if it's a worker doing
something like heavy processing
and it takes long time
and it's communicating
through a Pub/Sub,
stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Even then, you
could do that with Managed VMs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Even then, you
could do it with Managed VMs
if you really needed to.
So far, what I do is I start
with App Engine by default.
And if I cannot really do it
on App Engine but it's really,
really close, like
a small thing,
then I consider Managed VMs.
Otherwise, if it
doesn't really match,
I will start with
Compute Engine.
But really quick, I will
move to Container Engine
because it's so much
easier to manage.
MARK MANDEL: I would
agree with that.
ROMIN IRANI: So can I just
follow up with a slight--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, go for it.
ROMIN IRANI: What about
concurrency stuff on Go?
If you try to run those
things on App Engine,
how does it work?
MARK MANDEL: There is some
limitations on App Engine.
There is a single thread
for running goroutines
on App Engine, and
that's just the one.
Generally speaking,
from my experience,
it's never really
been a huge issue.
Especially for web
stuff, it's not
like you're going to be
doing that much stuff.
If you need to expand
upon that, then, yes,
start looking to go further down
that abstraction pathway to go
to Managed VMs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I could say that the biggest
restriction is that you
can only run one thread.
But that doesn't mean you
can only run one goroutine.
You can run as many
goroutines as you need.
Important thing is that all
the goroutines will be stopped
when the HTTP handler finishes.
So you cannot have one goroutine
that is started by the handler
and keeps on running
for one hour.
That's not something
that we allow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
But then you'd just
use task queues.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Then you can use task queues.
And then in task queues, again,
you can use as many goroutines
as you want.
So yeah.
ROMIN IRANI: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
for joining us.
Thanks to Romin Irani
for coming by the booth
and asking such an
interesting question.
We got to have a really
good chat about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And Go related.
MARK MANDEL: It was
Go related, too.
That makes Francesc
very, very happy.
Excellent.
So I know is that as of
this podcast recording,
I will be at Strada.
I'll be helping running
the code labs there.
So if you're listening to the
podcast and at that event,
please swing by and say hello.
I would love to say hi.
I'll be wearing my Google Cloud
Platform Podcast t-shirt, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yeah.
But if you're a listener, we
actually now have t-shirts.
Maybe if you find
us at some event,
we'll be able to
provide you with some.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Limited edition.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Limited
edition, totally.
MARK MANDEL: Are you going to be
anywhere special anytime soon?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not really.
I'm going to go to
DevRelCon, which
is a conference for
DevRellers-- developer relations
engineers-- in San Francisco.
So that's going to be,
like, five minutes walking.
I like those trips.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
Let me know how that goes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
That's great.
Well, if people want to
get in contact with us,
where can they go, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, I know those.
So we are on Twitter.
We're pretty active on Twitter.
So it's @GCPPodcast.
We are also on Google
Plus at +GCPPodcast.
We are also on Reddit on the
subreddit, /r/GCPPodcast.
We also have a web
page, GCPPodcast.com.
And an e-mail,
hello@GCPPodcast.com.
And I think I'm
not forgetting any.
MARK MANDEL: No, you are.
Slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
We're also on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, on
GCP community Slack,
we're at a hash podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And what
is the URL to access that?
MARK MANDEL: If people
want to join Slack,
the URL is bit.ly/GCP-slack.
That's the inviter
that they can go in on.
And they'll be able
to connect from there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
And yeah, we've actually been
receiving more emails recently.
We're very happy about that.
We're going to be answering some
of the questions of the week
that you sent us
in next episodes.
Don't worry about that.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Well, thank you very much
for joining me, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
very much for joining me today
and joining me during GCP Next.
That was an awesome experience.
MARK MANDEL: It was
absolutely fantastic.
And I'll see you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]